yeah yeah so we had so we had the we
have a lot of sugarcane in australia uh
yeah during like the 1800s and then cane
flies were introduced which are these
specific breed of flies that only eat ca
sugarcane and which completely wiped out
a cane
and we're like well [ __ ] we're gonna get
rid of these flies because our food is
getting [ __ ] up yeah and then someone
was like
i've heard overseas there was a specific
type of toad called the cane toad that
specifically only eats cane flies
someone thought oh it's brilliant
that's gonna solve all of our problems
let's let's introduce it so they
introduced it yeah all the cane flies
disappeared but then somebody realized
[ __ ] nothing eats cane toads
and they're literally poisonous and
they're killing our native animals
so now we just have a cane toad outbreak
and you just can't get rid of it and we
just can't get rid of them dude it's
like me playing chess they like suddenly
thought one move ahead they were like
they didn't plan anything else like this
feels like a vast oversight in like
possible downsides yeah there's no pros
and cons lists someone was like bro my
mate's got one bring it over yeah let's
just test it out sounds like the
beginning of like an always sunny skit
right
like
you're just like oh let's bring over the
cane toads and you just you just see
like the [ __ ] intro intro title gang
choice gang introduces cane toads to the
to the food chain
and then again australia hasn't had very
much luck with uh animals i mean we had
an emu war and we lost yeah i i'm like
what what the [ __ ] is that about like i
i hear every australian say that and i'm
just like that just sounds like i said
the great emu awards are the dumbest
[ __ ] ever yeah they went to war against
and they lost and we lost how did you
okay would you want to explain that dude
have you seen an emu no they're [ __ ]
terrifying can they kill you yeah okay
it's australia everything can kill you
should have known that one yeah
were they eating crops
yeah they were ruining crops uh and and
again like they kind of just like over
bred themselves to the point where there
was just a [ __ ] ton of emus and just not
enough space so they started invading
farmland obviously farmers got pissed
off about it so they tried to get them
out of it but obviously it's one man
versus a [ __ ] two and a half meter
bird
that can literally just kick you in the
chest and kill you
so uh i think it went on for like
a month or something i don't know how
long it was it was a very short bit it
was a
so much money and like ammunition and
time ammunition yeah yeah they were
shooting them they were shooting
themselves they were like trying to gun
them down yeah where they could bet like
they're but the emus were literally like
the spartans and they were like yeah
because they wouldn't
it was like we we were like xerxes army
and the emus were the spartans they're
like oh [ __ ] because they would like
they weren't fighting them but they were
just they just kept getting away yeah it
was like a looney tunes
they couldn't they couldn't kill them it
was just like the benny hill theme for
later monsters
they had to wait and ambush them that's
how they
see it because they travel in flocks
yeah they they they go together in
flocks and they were trying to ambush
them and they're also extremely fun they
can run like 60 70 cases now the moment
they started opening fire on them they
just ran away and they would only kill
like you know like
maybe yeah but they wasted like a
hundred grand in ammo like ammo isn't
cheap i feel like because we're so used
to war you think the ammo is like
affordable yeah like ammo is super
expensive yeah so they were just wasting
hundreds of thousands of dollars on
bullets especially when that war was
happening it was probably even more
expensive and then one day someone was
like
it's not worth it is it no it's wave the
white flag and then they just retreated
and yeah it was embarrassing sounds like
a huge embarrassment so what was the
outcome of this war
what is going on in australia i'm sure
everyone who's like watched internet
videos has heard about this yeah like
this is a very internet video topic this
sounds like an internet historian skit
you know like yeah surprise he hasn't
made a video on it yeah to be honest
it's great material
yeah i mean it's it sounds like on the
same level as like you know the 4chan
tumblr wars or something like that
what do you what do you think
it just doesn't sound like it really has
just feels like the the laziest strategy
of killing them you know like there were
people who knew there were people who
died as well during the great evening
you walked i feel like nobody thought
this plan through like surely there was
a better way of getting them you know
what i mean like that's what pisses me
off most it was the laziest solution
they're like firing squad and they were
like yeah okay like nobody thought is
this really the best idea you know yeah
they were probably because someone
probably took one look at the [ __ ]
shotgun they had and they were like we
got this
easy double
we need a [ __ ] hollywood breakdown on
this you know where where where's the
hollywood summer blockbuster of the
australian emu war come on come on come
on hollywood get it together there's a
story line there man versus
should have carpets zack snyder come on
this is this is the next black slider
film
it's like a 300 spin-off
planet the apes from the perspective of
the emus fighting off the enemies emus
together strong
i would watch it but yeah that's what
the emu's winning perspective of the
emus yeah one of them is voiced by uh
raymond from everyone loves raymond get
back nicholas cage come on yeah nicholas
cage is what is the is the main role
rate and the supporting role is ringing
he goes insane as the eevees win
there's a part where raymond dies
you know he gets shot and then
freaking his mind he's freaking out
i can't go on
but he has to